who what are you talking about captain
america
from poses to fighting moves loads of
references to the mcu are made in the
film black widow
we've discovered the truth of origin's
past and gotten hints to the strength of
the connection between natasha and elena
these references and more help us
understand the stories of the marvel
world
which character shows off fight moves
belonging to some of the avengers
how about the heartbreaking line from
avengers infinity war that
surprisingly hurt again in this movie
perfect timing
poison avenger when you need one the
taskmaster brings
loads of action to black widow and a lot
of it looks
very familiar the taskmaster is actually
mimicking many of the movements of other
marvel characters
like hawkeye with her stellar bow skills
and black panther with a copy of the
black panther claws in the red room
not to mention the captain america nod
with the shield stamp being pulled out
in a fight
and of course black widow with her
huracana rana moves
the knife trick bucky barnes does in
captain america the winter soldier
also appears to be in the taskmaster's
repertoire
what is that supposed to mean the
taskmaster isn't the only one to pay
tribute
to bucky barnes florence pew as helena
shows off the same move during black
widow
what makes this reference especially
interesting is the fact that it gives us
a clue that
elena and barnes might have undergone
some of the same training how is this
relevant
the safe house in budapest is a place
that we have heard of before in the mcu
you and i remember budapest very
differently
the so-called bullet holes as elena
mistakes them
were actually caused by arrows during a
standoff battle that was brought up
before in the avengers film
it's a small but really powerful
connection for us in the mcu
this line may just be the black widow's
catchphrase
thank you for your cooperation natasha's
smug thank you for your cooperation line
to dracov was heard coming from ramanov
in the avengers film as well
it's the same way she leaves off her
interrogation with loki in the movie
thank you for your cooperation it's a
pretty great catchphrase
so we wouldn't be surprised if it stuck
around from here on out
the green vest that yelena is seen
wearing has been seen before
this is the same jacket natasha ramanov
was wearing during the battle of wakanda
in avengers infinity war what's extra
special about this reference is that
it's a clear nod to the strength of the
relationship between natasha
and elena's sisters we are definitely
very big fans of this sweet connection
can we do that
poor scott lang being forgotten is
becoming a regular joke in the mcu now
in black widow we see his name being
forgotten when ross references lange as
a
shrinking convict we got barton we got
wilson and the other guy the incredible
shrinking convict
among clint barton and sam wilson both
who get called by name
tony stark started the gag in captain
america civil war
and lang even tried to make a snarky
comment about never being able to trust
a stark
and pim always said you never can trust
a stark stark definitely wins this quip
though
who are you what lang did to end up
being constantly forgotten
we're not so sure i know you know a lot
of super people so
thanks for thanking of me natasha
romanov's poses
are signature to her style but that
doesn't mean that they're above being
teased
elena spends a chunk of time mimicking
the over-sexualized poses that romanov
did
much earlier in the mcu films one
landing elena makes is almost the exact
same one that natasha does in iron man 2
but she isn't a fan and instead actually
calls it
disgusting the black widow poses get
even more references though
when molina disguised as natasha wakes
up on the floor
the pose looks extremely similar to the
awkward photo of johansen that was
photoshopped onto the captain america
the winter soldier film poster romanov
was also in an eerily similar position
when she fell to her end in avengers end
game
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser
this is the first time we've gotten to
see general dracov but
it's certainly not the first time we've
heard of him in the mcu
in the avengers film the name was
brought up during an intense
confrontation between natasha and loki
while loki was challenging natasha on
all of her sins insisting she couldn't
be redeemed
the mention of dracov's daughter didn't
really mean a whole lot
now we understand he was referring to
the fact that the black widow was the
one responsible for drakov's daughter's
death
drakov's daughter
natasha's family begins their escape in
ohio in 1995
but not without being followed by the
authorities
of course this isn't just regular cops
on the jeeps here we can see a logo of
an earlier version of the shield logo
it may be different from the one we're
used to but it's definitely shield
that's on the romanovs family's tail
today's the day yay at first
we think the disk of tech secrets comes
from a place called
the north institute however later we
learn it's actually a front for shield
but just to make things even more
complex
this was a time that hydra was actually
infiltrating and running shield
this all checks out with what we learned
in captain america the winter soldier
about the fact that hydra had actually
been behind the scenes a shield for
quite a while a beautiful parasite
inside shield we still get emotional
thinking of peter parker's heartbreaking
final line from avengers infinity war
when he meets his end i don't want to go
i don't want to go
we were definitely caught off guard to
hear that very familiar line again in
black widow
in the beginning of the movie molina
uses the words when explaining she
doesn't want to leave ohio
it's of course not as devastating a
moment but it's still a really nice
callback
i don't wanna go clearly things are not
and have not been great between natasha
and tony stark
by the end of the civil war film we saw
the two's relationship
totally break and move towards becoming
estranged from one another
a small and subtle comment from natasha
regarding the super scientist
is a great mention of her not so great
past with stark
tony stark maybe oh yeah we're not
really talking right now so
we got a taste of hawkeye from the
taskmaster with the skillful bow work
but he does get a few more pretty
significant mentions in black widow
his presence was still there even if he
wasn't on the screen physically
in a flashback to budapest we see
footage of natasha being spoken to by
hawkeye through her earpiece sasha
are we clear looking for the go-ahead to
set off some explosives
we get to actually see hawkeye's face as
well in a picture at least
on an ipad handed to elena his photo is
pulled up on the screen and makes a
solid impact on the black widow's
history in the mcu
in avengers it shared that clint barton
is the one meant to kill natasha
yet the circumstances have shifted this
moment is also a great lead-in for elena
who we know will be
appearing in the hawkeye series i've got
your next target
i thought i'd hand deliver it black
widow brings us
a somewhat surprising callback to the
hydra miracles program
when molina confirms the fact that
natasha was being used because of her
genetic potential
it gives us a connection to the maximoff
twins wanda and pietro who were the two
successful subjects from that hydra
program
the nanomask face swap trick is amazing
but it's not the first time we've seen
it used in the mcu
black widow used the trick to disguise
herself as councilwoman holly in front
of alex pierce
using the photostatic veil during a peak
moment in captain america
natasha made use of the handy tool again
in black widow when she disguised
herself in order to see drakov
sharon carter also happened to use this
same disguise method
in the falcon in the winter soldier
series if it works
it works what
what these smart and detailed references
have really added to the richness of the
mcu
it's great to see these moments brought
up again and jokes ragging on characters
like ant-man
to some killer lines from prior movies
which hidden references did you catch in
black widow